is there other stories or maybe you can
speak out at a high level what are you
hoping to tell and all these different
stories that are weaved
about um
that that connect
the the tragedies and the triumphs the
heroism of uh of that day and the and
the days and the years that followed
you know alex it seems like the common
few themes the common threads
are
being selfless
helping out others even though they
might be a stranger
in acts of kindness acts of love
and it seems to all be weaved together
with faith they all seem to have some
sort of faith i mean we have one
gentleman
mark hannah
and he he's a coptic egyptian priest
and he's
an immigrant to the united states he was
a port authority building engineer
and with his crew who subsequently
passed away
the crew did uh he was effectively
rescuing dozens of people on the upper
floors
and his boss ordered him to assist an
elderly gentleman who was 89
down 78 flights of stairs to get him out
and in stopping on the 21st floor
he figured they would just wait there
for medics he came across
captain patty brown of ladder company 3
who told him no sir you need to evacuate
and captain brown picked his brain a
little bit about the structure because
he figured he found out he was an
engineer
and captain patty brown continued on to
defect rescues and he and his crew were
killed
but father he's now mark was able to
effectively evacuate this gentleman they
were the two known last survivors to
come out of the tower
he now has dedicated his life to
becoming a coptic priest in st mary's
church in east brunswick new jersey
he did this for a total stranger and he
said he was inspired by his his bosses
who died
and uh his friends you know one of his
best friends was an italian man the
other man was a retired navy seal
hispanic man
and they were part of this melting pot
and no one looked at each other that day
what color what race what belief were
you they just said hey you're a human in
need let's go.
and
you know we have uh the story about john
feel on his mission to to help the
responders
um we have a young lady mariah who's
whose birth father was on flight 93 she
had not even met him
and she had this premonition that
somebody in her family was killed that
day and
and her adopted mom said no everyone's
fine well three years later when she was
legally able to find out who her dad was
she found out that her dad tom was
actually on that plane as part of the
let's roll team
and
we have a gentleman robert burke who's
an actor
sweetheart of a man he's a gentleman and
he's a very very popular actor in
hollywood he's on rescue me blue bloods
gossip girls and
and bobby my friend as i call him is is
a volunteer fireman now this man doesn't
need to get out of bed at two o'clock in
the morning and help people with a
stroke or a burning garage or a burning
house but he does because he wants to
because his best friend was captain
patty brown
and his other best friend was father
michael judge who was our chaplain
who was killed literally blessing the
victims at the site
had just given last rites to the
firefighter i mentioned earlier danny
who was killed
and father judge was in the lobby of the
building giving a blessing praying to
god to please stop this
and he was struck by debris and he was
killed
and
bobby goes on to elaborate about father
judge's story father judge used to walk
the streets of new york city helping
aids patients just with whatever they
needed and
he was a franciscan friar they wear
sandals and a robe they're just
they just live very humble lives of
and it's just the common denominator is
loving each other
and helping each other regardless of you
know the person or not
and really when you think about it
that's how america was made we we fought
for independence stranger
fought next to stranger
and and fought tyranny and because they
wanted freedom they wanted to be able to
live love
pray
and prosper
and they fought and died alongside of
strangers and it's sort of symbolic of
what happened that day and then
strangers from around this great country
just flocked in
by the thousands to help
they didn't know who was in that pile
but they didn't care that was another
american
and what i ultimately am trying to do
involved in this beautiful project
is
spread the message of doing the right
thing
look at these examples
these brave people who didn't have to
especially the civilians they weren't
paid to run back in there and help
person after person and
they had no obligation they could have
just said hey man i'm out of here and
just bolted
but they didn't
so we're just trying to say to people
let's bring back that unity and that
feeling of 9 12.
as strange as 9 12 of a day it was it
was so sad because
it we it was the first dawn of the sun
where we realized this wasn't a dream
this was real and it's not going away
but the beauty of it was there was
thousands of people lined up along the
west side highway with signs
and american flags
and they were from every country and
every race and every creed and it didn't
matter who they were but they all shared
one bond love
and they were hugging and crying
and thanking rescuers
and it brought the morale so high
for a group of people that was so beaten
down the day before
it just started lifting them around
making us realize you know what
people really do give a crap they really
do love each other
and now i'm gonna be honest with you
i've been doubting that a little bit
lately
i still have these examples of it you
know that lady who helped me last night
with the phone and just you know i know
there's these shining little examples
but sometimes i think
i don't know are we running out of them
well i got to give you some advice
says uh two words that were repeated
often
in the days and the years after 9 11
which is never forget yeah
might i remind you
to never forget about 9 12.
i mean those words uh you talked about
that you know there's people
what is it college freshman maybe they
weren't even born they weren't even born
and there's people in the 20s that were
too young to remember to understand the
events of that day
but i think what that day as you're
describing means it's not about a
terrorist attack it's about the unity
that followed it was tremendous lex i
never felt so proud i was always proud
of this country
you know i remember my grandpa nails
used to walk by i'd see a flag i hear a
star spangled banner and he'd tear up
and i'd say grant why are you crying he
said
i'm not crying as the tears of joy i
love this country so much
and i just remember like feeling that
way i felt that way 9 10
i felt that way on 9 11 but then on 9 12
i was just so proud of just the people
the way they stepped up
and i just want to try to see if that
can happen again and i hope it's it's
not necessary for us to have another
tragedy to bring that about
let's do that without the tragedy let's
just stop and say hey
you know what let me listen to what this
guy has to say
and maybe he's he probably won't
convince me but maybe i'll go well you
know i never thought of it that way
stop the finger-pointing the bickering
the tantrums the fighting it's just not
necessary it gets you nowhere right it's
like you know i was two years old and i
stomp around because i wanted a cookie
or a piece of candy i still didn't get
it right you know turned blue in the
face and whatever got a swat in the rear
end but didn't get the candy
and that's what we got going on right
now everybody's just stomping around
being a baby
stop just stop we're really lucky look
country's not perfect right
you know but it's damn good yeah it
gives us all these opportunities you
know like i said no one's rushing out
the gates to get out of here they're
they're freaking
i got a cousin of mine i love them
dearly my cousin tony in ireland
and he said he's he's just a little
older than me in his 50s he said man
i should have done it
i should have went to america my dad
said go to america i went to england
and he went back to ireland and you know
he but he's happy in ireland it's his
home but he said wow what a place of
opportunity and i said it's never too
late he goes yeah but you know what you
get tied down and i understand that
i thank god my mom came here at 16. i
thank god my grandpa got on that ship
but
in his 20s 27 i think you know when not
a nickel to rub together i thank god
they did it because i don't know where
else i would have ended up
there's no place else i want to be
and uh i thank god that there's people
like you who rushed towards ground zero
to help other human beings
and i believe that that that human
spirit is ultimately represents the best
this country and the best of this world
you know thank you for the stories
you're telling
for your perseverance and that
and uh thank you for welcoming me to the
crew
you're very
you can do the job just fine i love
lifting heavy things that's doing
dangerous things so um it's i'm proud to
be part part of this country and part of
the tally hall now well you are you are
definitely an attribute to america and
we're glad you chose to come here um you
know like it's
it's such a beautiful place it's a
beautiful melting pot you know if we're
all the same it would be kind of a
boring place right kind of boring it
really would but it just it's just such
a great place and i just want to say
thanks it's an honor
it's an honor to have someone to let me
sound off and and it'll be even bigger
on her if somebody will listen to me and
just say hey you know let me just try to
do something good today and you know
that's that's the tunnel to towers
mantras let us do good
and i just you know
i uh
i got a really big credit card with god
a big balance right i i need to pay him
back a lot and i need to pay him forward
and
i'm just going to spend the rest of my
days trying my best i don't know where
this is going to go what it'll lead into
but
i really would like to get those dogs
for those vets and build them that
village and just keep going on from
project to project to just say
when my final day comes
and i'm laying there and i say you know
what
i really made the most of that second
chance god gave me way back in 2011 i
mean i hope it's 30
40 years from now but even if it's 30
months from now or
giving it the best shot so thank you sir
i appreciate it and uh wishing you
blessings and success in your career
keep up the good fight and you're always
welcome back to texas well i love it
it's great food and uh a little hot a
little hot ah come on
we don't do so good irish in the sun you
know but uh well the barbecue and the
people are worth it no they are awesome
i was down here for some storm relief a
few years ago um and i tell you what i
fell in love with it the people are
great it's a great state and
yeah i'll definitely definitely be back
again for sure thanks for talking to
danielle thank you sir appreciate it
you